so we're 1 ounces after the beat up
whoever announced the job go back to the
pizza table all right so who is hiring
and waited Jarek first up right here
yeah we're hiring we're always hiring
yeah odd AWS we having everything from
their scientists data engineers dictator
people and business rodney managers
essentially what I do we need to scale
so let me know if you're interested what
was the company it's a book store that
is trying to
come on over hey guys my name is Troy
another right here
yeah
all right is from so this is
[Music]
[Music]
a bar and grill
all right you'll be at the bar our
speaker with the barn ask any
complicated question friend Charlotte if
you want to attend strata in September
it's tell me up soon we have a discount
code we just confirmed today it's
working if someone message me and wasn't
working it is down it is Yugi my half
r20 yugi user and white hat are fun
so go save some money
our next meetup we have it yeah it's
supposed to be worked out the art studio
Roadshow a few folks mark studio going
to come here and show us some the cool
new stuff they've been developing so
stay tuned at some point we are going to
get that going to lockdown so we covered
jobs are even those have any less than
of things with that represents you Donna
Banga talking about deep learning in
general and in particular in our so a
big round of applause for Dan
oh thank you
I hope the presentation in the end it's
worth the applause all right so getting
started my name is Dan Roman banger I do
business development at Amazon Web
Services essentially what I do for my
focus is on machine learning and deep
learning engines I work with customers
of any size from startups to Fortune 100
that want to build and grow on top of
AWS so it varies from finding
opportunities for them or optimizing
whatever they do or finding new ways of
doing what they do currently I want to
start this presentation by saying thank
you this usually gets left for the end
another presentation but I want to begin
by this because I appreciate the fact
that you have a lot of emails in your
mailbox and then you're spending this
hour hour and a half with with us today
so essentially what we're going to cover
tonight is an introduction high-level
understanding so that we get on the same
page as far as deep learning is
concerned AI and then the second thing
I'm going to talk about is what we do at
Amazon internally how we leverage the
opportunity of machine learning and deep
learning and what we use these tools is
interesting new tools for and the third
thing that we're going to talk about is
library called Apache MX nap which is an
open source project and I'm gonna tell
I'm gonna speak a lot more about and
it's essentially a deep learning library
which has interesting interesting
features and that's what we're going to
cover and one of the interesting
features is that is that it supports our
as a high level interface and the last
thing we're going to do is we're going
to dig into an example code of using MX
net and taking advantage of the
opportunities of deep learning inside
our infrastructure okay that's a good
agenda so to begin I want to start by
telling a story of the you know what we
call the flywheel of data where we are
technically more and more data is being
generated nowadays by virtually everyone
in a LAN we're using mobile phones we
have our fitbit's that is generating
data
mobile applications there's data
everywhere there's a humongous amount of
data being generated nowadays in the
world and better data gives you better
analysis so the more data you have the
more analysis you can get on from that
data set and better analytics gives you
a better product when you get better
product from better analysis then you
get more users and more users generate
more data and then there goes the
flywheel the way you like extreme and
then user activity on your website and
your web app purchases creaks and then
likes on social networks and other
things like that
you also get better nowadays from the to
such people leverage to do better and
analytics are things like objects store
databases yeah I think people are very
much familiar with most of those the
Hadoop ecosystem was born about four or
five years ago a little story I started
off at Amazon as a big data operations
manager so I sought to build the support
team in Cape Town South Africa for big
data and so I remember back in those
days when you went on two or three
different websites and read about Big
Data you would have had two or three
different definitions it's almost the
same thing now with AI and machine
learning where the hype is on everyone
is interested in it but a few people can
really define what it is so the tools
down here as far as Hadoop spark and
presto are you know the new de facto
standards that people are getting used
to and this is the new opportunity right
new opportunity is to use artificial
intelligence and AI and data science and
all these statistical learning tools to
analyze data better and essentially get
better product and then better products
gonna give it up the opportunity to
pinpoint your users understanding users
better and essentially generate more
data and of you go try well please feel
free to interrupt me at any time if I
have a question I'm happy to keep this
interactive as we go now understanding
artificial intelligence you know just to
make sure we're on the same line like I
said you get multiple definitions if you
go on multiple websites the way we see
is that AI is of the umbrella term that
encompasses everything right so it's a
combination of learning
Goren's Lud's hardware that essentially
interfaces with the real world when you
deal with artificial intelligence the
the thing that we are trying to
replicate is ability for humans to or
the ability for computers to emulate or
simulate human systems expert systems
that humans do without really being able
to break it down to a certain finite set
of steps if they ask you how you see you
you know that you learn how tis you know
that you can see but you can't really
break it down so how do you encode that
into a computer if they ask you how you
speak you you know that as a child you
learn how to speak but how do you teach
a computer how to speak we converse you
can say things in certain words but I
will understand the mean how to say
what's on your mind
how do you make sure how do we make that
a computer can get the intent of a
person regardless of what word was
saying so these are the sort of
opportunities that you get an AI and so
the way we see AI it's an interaction
between the real world and the computer
and then that to be as seamless as
possible so then you get application
like surf driving cards playing games
and then automated turbine or predictive
maintenance a number of things that
really interact for the real world but
are driven by computers and then machine
learning is sort of the the workforce or
workforce for a is as in in AI you need
to identify patterns in data and machine
learning gives you the statistical
background or the mathematical approach
to essentially fit a certain function to
the data so in ml you the analogy that I
use is that in AI data is like the soil
and then in the soil you plant on a
machine learning algorithm and then
grows out of it another machine learning
algorithm right so you plan to learn
algorithm into the data and then you
grow the other you know the machine
learning model represents your data and
then so machine learning is a mass part
of it I put I put this here to look a
little smart like I got I know what I'm
talking about
and then so deep learning takes a soft
field that has to do with neural network
that traditionally it's very old concept
back in the 30s and 40s figured out
already but it was a challenge in terms
of computing and data that we're gonna
get to talk about but deep learning it's
this is the prime time for
it's over we figured out how to get
compute way faster than the way the
silicon in the CPU evolves and then
there's also a lot of data like we
talked about that gives us that you need
to leverage that and with GPU deep
learning can take neural networks to the
next level and essentially give people
the possibility to fit a network
structure on top of data so the
opportunity that we see now the three
the three main drivers for seizing the
opportunity for AI machine learning are
fast compute with sorry
well we figured out how to process data
a lot faster with GPU ubiquitous data
where we figure out what social network
and everything that comes around with it
how to essentially have a better
knowledge representation of the world
and then advanced learning algorithms
where nowadays because again leveraging
computing data we can generate more and
more Universal approximation functions
and every day there's a new paper at
their serial models and you know
multi-armed bandit which is a new sexy
like there's a lot more new cool things
that are coming out now in terms of
advanced learning algorithms I give us
the opportunity of artificial
intelligence and AI machine learning and
deep learning so this is a prime time
for data scientists this is a prime time
for machine learning enthusiasts and
this is yeah that's a good time so the
way we leverage a at Amazon is in a few
a few ways search and discovery
everything on on the amazon.com page is
essentially driven by AI and machine
learning and deep learning the way we we
rank the product that we're going to
present the way we decide what asset
we're gonna present the recommender
systems I used to tell the story I buy
expresso capsules on amazon.com and then
essentially two days before I run out I
get a notification do you want to buy it
again
you know so they sort of predict you
know whenever I'm gonna need a refill
and it's all driven by machine learning
and fulfillment and logistics in our in
our fulfillment centers we don't have
people running around you know picking
up boxes and things like that we have
these 758 bins that are we essentially
throw things in there
we're using a random storage mechanism
and we use computer vision to recognize
whatever is within the bins and then we
have surviving robots that pick them up
and then move them around fulfillment
center and present that to people down
at the end of the at the end of the line
and then an agent can just pick up the
item and label and ship that out I don't
know most self-driving they go around
when they run out of battery they go and
recharge themselves and they come back
and move around it's really cool I have
a demo video that I can show later and
we have new categories for existing
products like essentially using
optimization to make products better our
goal is really to bring machine learning
to all to everyone and that AWS Amazon
Web Services is the conduit for that is
the way we want to extract that entire
knowledge from amazon.com and other
business units and then present that to
our customers in forms of platforms and
services
like that yeah better okay cool so this
was our first recommended system it's
the Amazon home webpage in 1997-1998
where essentially we had already
personal notification services going
around and that was someone in the
backend taking a list of what people
bought another list of our people bought
and doing the matching manually and say
hey we should recommend this to that guy
and someone sent in that notification so
the mindset was around for a long time
and then now we just taken advantage of
you know the tools and automation
platform to make it faster it's another
example of application of machine
learning or AI at Amazon if you use
Amazon video if you post a show or
anything you watching there's this tool
called x-ray which essentially pulls up
in real-time information about the
actors within the scene at exact scene
where you you hit pause so the
interesting thing here is that as you
can see we're not using a naive facial
detection mechanism the actors are
giving their back to the camera but
we're still able to recognize who they
are and then we'll give you more
information about them and we can point
you to some other movies that they've
been in and things like that all
happening in real time
of course everyone is familiar with echo
who here is not familiar with echo much
everyone okay so the reason I like
talking about echo devices is that it's
an interesting delivery mechanism
because I think part of a conversation
within the next few months in almost a
year it's gonna get into you have a
machine learning model then what so how
do you scale that how do you make it
work in a non internet-connected
environment or how do you make it work
in a hybrid environment where you have
the internet partially and then you
don't have any internet anymore so echo
really embodies that concept where you
have a very very small model running
locally that whose only job is to
identify wake up word right when you see
Alexa or echo or history or all these
you know voice systems the only job of
the model that which is very lightweight
running on the machine is to identify
the wake up word and once once that is
done it opens up an mp3 streams and a
new stream in the command that is sent
to the cloud and then the rest of its
process to the cloud and rest of
intelligence happens there we have
another device
people that like fashion it's called an
echo show where this is echo look sorry
the echo show has a has a screen where
essentially you can say Alexa take a
picture of me it's gonna take a picture
of you and it's going to give you
recommendations about what to wear this
type of jacket goes with that kind of
jeans and what now if people want wanted
to have a personal assistant and so we
made it happen for them and it can it
can get the history of the things that
you've done in the past that you wore in
the past and you could say what should I
wear today or tomorrow and it will go
okay you typically dress up that way so
you might want to wear this and that so
it's it makes some people love to make
some people happy so it's so these are
examples more examples of how we
leverage deep learning and a at AWS for
Applied Research core research Alexa
demand forecasting pretty much
everything is driven decision it's
driven by a model in the backend or
accelerated by a model in the backend
right we're natural language processing
understanding content recognition
dynamic asset generation what are we
going to present at what time based on
the customers behavior page all these
things are driven by AI so this this is
a list of customers that currently
leverage it up this platform for
Egyptian intelligence Zillow is a good
example where they do price estimate of
houses on top of AWS Netflix is an
obvious one nASA uses a AWS to give
voice commands to to the robots and then
it's a lot more Pinterest for these are
cool examples as well
Pinterest does visual search on top of
AWS where essentially you can start with
a picture like that and then crop a lamp
within the picture and do a visual
search of the lamp and then come up with
other images or pictures of lamp that
are similar to that based on a picture
and then in beta they have a Pinterest
lens which is essentially an app this is
a model running on the phone where you
can take a picture of an object or of
someone in the way and then it's gonna
search the space of pins and then show
you other images that have similar
pictures or objects so a good a lot of
momentum in the in an image recognition
domain and then Netflix uses AWS for
personalized rank
Paige generation search similarity
analysis the whole recommender systems
and then they had to scale in about 140
countries essentially by porting the
data because localizing the data a
little more and then analyzing that
locally and then generating the models
from that in production that quick so in
the space of a bit more fun example this
is this is called neuro style transfer
where I bet you all have cameras that
change the texture the structure of a
picture nowadays and and that's those
are variants of neuro style transfer
where you can start with a with an image
like this and then you sort of overlay
the image with a painting and then after
that you generate a completely this is
completely generative where I've
generated so you can generate a
completely new image that essentially
replicates the model of this image and
applies the style of the of the second
image so you rotate the pixels of the
first image and then you apply this
style to generate gesture stuff so we
might wonder what the hell am I going to
do with newer style transfer this is the
paper called bring impression to life
with neuro style transfer income swing
essentially in this paper people they
had an intro scene and it was some form
of horror movie so from the intro scene
they wanted to apply the style of the
painting that represented the horror
movie and then generated another video
of the intro scene of a guy drowning
using the style of the horror movie so
you can think about a few things you you
want to do with it
this particular paper got the collective
machine learning and data science
community to lose their collective mind
because the second author on this paper
is Kristen Stewart who is Bela in
Twilight so essentially AI and machine
learning is for everyone you know need
to have a PhD or whatnot whatever people
say is absolutely you know not true so
the team that I work for is called
Amazon AI and essentially what we want
to do is bring these capabilities and
knowledge or the experience that we have
in form of platforms and services and
I'm not going to talk about all of these
because this talk is not about that but
that was a long intro to actually you
know focusing on deep learning and MX
and
and that's what we're gonna talk about a
little later so at the top layer though
we have a lot of services which is you
know a pre-trained machine learning and
deep learning models that we train we
scale in the backend and we make
available in front of an API and
remember when I was talking about these
expert systems you know how does the
machine see how does the machine speak
how does the machine interact with
humans and understand the intent of a
person these are the kind of problems
that we're trying to solve with these
services and we're trying to make sure
that our customers don't have to do it
themselves so either from a vision
perspective we have technician from a
speech perspective we have a
text-to-speech solution called Pali and
then from a chatbot perspective we have
legs which is essentially the brain for
like Sarah we took out and they were
made available for people to build their
own chat pod and then underneath that
layer we have what we call the
platform's which is for people that have
their own data that they want to train
machine learning and deep learning
models on and machine learning as of now
and they they still they don't want to
do the plumbing right they they want to
get started at a point where they can
just start building models data
scientists usually didn't want to have
to do with infrastructure I don't care
where you get a cluster from I want to
see Zeppelin I want to see the are the
jupiter notebook i want to see you know
the our interface so it's got the
problem that which on the south there
we're doing devops for data scientists
right and amazon machine learning gives
you an end-to-end way of uploading your
data training it and then deploying that
behind an api as of now it's of course
linear regression logistic regression
the multi-class classification if you
want to get deeper into other models
like three based models or support
vector machines or other stuff you can
use spark machine learning on top of AWS
and in terms of ingesting data for
processing or if you want to darker eyes
your environment you can use ETS or
Canisius or batch we will talk about
that more later but I'm not gonna focus
on that today what I'm going to focus on
is the deep learning opportunities so
under that layer of course we have
infrastructure we have GPU CPU and
we build stuff that run on IOT devices
or mobile devices but area of interest
here is is the engines layer where we
prepackaged environments and make them
available for people to start building
deep learning models so with that Jared
and I actually had long conversations
about what's the opportunity of you know
deep learning for for data Sciences like
why would I shoot data scientists be
interested in deep learning and I yeah
yeah we yeah so yeah we have Karis cafe
pretty much all the popular yeah so I
don't yeah wherever you see tensorflow
nowadays in piano you probably have
carrots unless you really want to suffer
right you know so I think you know
carrots intend to fold a and a piano or
MXN for that matter because they all
work you know together people people
want to go into the high level you know
library yeah
this way okay
and shoulder
like that further have a have a mic
assistant here ok cool thank you yeah
yeah so so that's what we do and so I
think that you know the opportunity
you're so deep learning does essentially
I usually say that principal component
now it's one layer you know deep
learning of you know MLP you know so
it's it's about the opportunity of
throwing more data and more compute at
your problem and then get potentially
more accuracy and we played around with
a few models where we we we created the
model with you know a neural network and
then we recreated a sim I was try to
solve the same problem with random
forests or well what else do we use we
use extra boots we use a few other you
know methods to try and solve the same
problem sometimes we had better accuracy
sometimes we have worse accuracy but the
whole thing here is that this layer
gives you the opportunity to scale it
gives you the opportunity to do a lot
more a lot more data and then to get
potentially hopefully better and better
and better accuracy something else that
people are doing is that they're trying
to use data set from other environments
like images you know how do you prefer
how do you make images up as part of
your data sources like rather than using
sensor and other kind of data what if
you know a picture is worth a thousand
words what if you use a neural network
as a pre-processing stage and get some
labels out of it and use that label to
those labels to augment the space of
features that you use for a traditional
you know support vector machine or
random forest model so that's the
opportunity and so deep learning gives
you the opportunity to you know solve
learning problems where you can
essentially get machines to to actually
learn without having to do hard-coded
you know feature engineering you don't
have to prepare the data set manually
yourself you can just throw that at the
model and it's going to do some
separation let you know you can do some
language learning you can we have open
source library called Sakai that
essentially gets you to do your machine
translation and that's one thing I like
talking about because if you could think
about the
where translation was done in the past
where you had to either use a word count
where you had to you know start with a
word and use the equivalent word in
another language or it improved then we
started using Engram where you use a
combination of words and then you were
translating that way and then approved
and then people were using sentences and
doing that but in all of these cases you
sort of have to build a whole database
of English and French version which
French is my first language by the way
so are you always use it as an example
you have to use whole database of these
you know two entities and then do the
mapping and so it's hard work to
maintain that but nowadays it's this
concept called nmt where if you think
about the way I see or the way I get
inputs in my system my brain gets
activated in a certain way if I see you
my mind gets in a certain state and
because if learning a neural networks
are about you know replicating the state
of the mind
into the machine the conceptual
assumption is that as we get input into
the system what if we were capable of
taking a snapshot of the brain
activation in artificial word that would
be taking a snapshot of the active
neurons and import that to another deep
neural network that is trained on doing
another thing like speaking French with
proper grammar right so instead of
translating the words you just ingest
words in English take the active neurons
pour that activation state into a
french-speaking neuron Network and let
it speak that thought or that you know
mind or whatever in French so that's the
kind of thing that we're trying to do
nowadays and I think we're gonna
converge towards getting a chip in my
head taken out and put it in your head
and you're just speaking right anyway so
and in perception is another way of
getting the machines to ca solve
problems and reasoning and so what we
have nowadays is called at the AWS deep
learning army it's one thing I'm gonna
give a short demo about that one quick
GPU deep learning machine image so in
AWS we have this construct of a virtual
machine called an ami we have
prepackaged with TAS the number of
engineers to essentially prepare this
machine for you to use right so they
update that
and then everytime this new version of
tensorflow Kara's cafe and all these
things they make sure that the new
version of the image is available we
have a boon to version and an Amazon
Linux version which is essentially a
derivative of samples so the machine can
go up to 40 thousand to the course and
Nvidia just announced or they announced
in May that they will release the volta
GPU chip which is which is a beast right
it has about 12x improvement on the
current pascal version of the GPU and
then we will be launch partners so once
the vaulter comes out we'll have that
available on ec2 and then it has tend to
flow MX net cafe and all this deep
learning framework pretty complete a pre
computer prepackaged for for GPU support
and everything has Python 3 Python 2 as
well a bunch of notebooks example and
then you also have the possibility to
launch a cluster of those using cloud
formation which is a decorative language
on a database environment to essentially
spin up an infrastructure without having
to hard code everything so that's what
we have now for people to get started
now we're gonna get into talking about
Apache MX net-like about library who
here is familiar with patchy MX net few
people ok good
how about deep learning in general tend
to flow other libraries ok a lot more
perfect so for those that are not
familiar with deep learning or MX net
essentially in deep learning you have to
create you know neural networks and for
those you have to and we're gonna get
through a process of solving a problem
and end with with you know with deep
learning but for those you have to stack
layers of layers of what we call neurons
that essentially get linear combinations
of a certain input set and then on those
linear combinations it decides it
randomly chooses a set of parameters and
then you stack this in your combinations
open up and on each yearned you have
what we call an activation function
which has usually has a threshold that
would determine whether the neuron is
going to get active or not remember when
I was talking about the state of a brain
you activate the cells within the brain
and things like that so you you start
from that simple linear combination
activation construct and then the
assumption is that you can stack that up
and up and up in multiple layers and
make some more complex stuff in order to
get deeper into the input set you're
trying to find paradigms for from a
layered perspective the simplest example
is that if you want to do image
recognition if you want to recognize a
person from a picture the assumption is
that you start with a pixels
I said pixel play and then you put that
in a two dimensional array x and y and
from the pixels as you ingest them the
first layer will potentially identify a
rough change in pixel that could be your
corner right if it's a picture of myself
between my skin and my t-shirt it'll
probably identify that there's a big
change in picture here so it would start
like at the first layer it would start
constructing the difference between
objects right the second layer
potentially would identify the same
pixel that is continuing so that's a
contour so you can start from corners by
identifying rough changing pixels and
you since out reconstructing contours by
essentially following the same object
around and you can bring it all the way
up to identify my t-shirt overall
identify my skin or identifying myself
right so the idea is that you have a
layered approach at solving problems and
that's the benefit of deep neural
networks and at the top of the layer
let's say I want to build a neural net
to identify myself in a picture right so
the eye will interest a number of
pictures and then also in chess label
that in the end we say this is Stan and
whomever the network identifies at as
you know the person there will be an
error there and then we go back into the
machine learning world where you have an
error function or an optimization
function and they need to do gradient
descent or every other type of
optimization in order to minimize the
error right so that's a whole concept
but because in deep neural network you
do that in the stage manner you have
multiple layers of errors you have
multiple neurons that are responsible
for the overall error and distribute the
brain how do you get every other neuron
within the new
network to take responsibility for the
overall error function right so there's
this concept called the chain rule in
derivatives where you essentially
propagate backwards and get the nurse to
take responsibility and adjust the
weights that come from the linear
combination in each of them in order to
get you the best configuration of the
neural network that gives you the
outcome that you want so the reason I
went through that whole history is that
it's much different complex to encode
all of that in a library and the
research world a lot of people have been
doing that manually like writing the
combination denomination building the
layers manually or the read deriving the
error function manually back to back to
back to back so the benefit for for
these deep learning libraries is that
they sort of automate a lot of these
things for you so all that you just say
construct your network by decoratively
and tell me I want one layer one layer
one layer one layer and then this is the
kind of outcome that I want from it and
I'm gonna take care of deriving the
error minimizing that just tell me how
you want to optimize that tell me what
the learning rate you want to have on
that and I'm gonna take up everything
else so that's the benefit and so
tensorflow is one library cafe is
another one you have a few one CNT k MX
net is another one that we back a little
us for a few reasons so there were a lot
of them in there industry by the time we
sort of had to choose one and we chose
one - which is called MX net and we sort
of made it part of most most of the
products that we're building now one of
the main reasons we chose it makes net
is that it's flexible it has a mixed
programming API where it supports many
languages of the front-end right so we
we don't want people to have to work
with Java in order to use you know you
know the tool we want data scientists to
use our because that's what they like
and then so with our or C++ or like the
backend is built in C++ but these are
the binding languages so at the top
layer you can build your networks with
any one of these languages and then as
you compile the code you know how to run
it it all runs in C so you don't lose in
performance you don't lose in anything
but you use an infrastructure or an
interface that you that you familiar
with it's also portable where
essentially you can build a neural net
work with apache MX net and it's fully
open source by the way so it's an apache
product Amazon Web Services contributes
about 46 percent of a code right now but
it's a number of other people in the
industry an ecosystem that that
contribute to so we have customers
building models with an X net and then
they run that on mobile devices on
drones in browsers with JavaScript and
it's also highly scalable the idea here
is that now when you start building
models and you want to take advantage of
a large data set then you start falling
into like in core memory issues I guess
it's just this much that the CPU can do
or GPU can do because it's memory bound
IO bounding if you want to throw more
data at it you have to scale out of the
machine and once you start scaling out
of the Machine you start getting into
cluster managers right all the machines
need to be in sync they need to talk to
each other you need to want to compute
the gradients you need to find out
exactly what is the latest state so all
that state management is cumbersome so
that makes net gives you the possibility
to almost linearly scaling the state
management issues make it make it worse
for a few scalable libraries because
that time managing your cluster consumes
the overall time of your exercise if you
started with a job that was taking I
don't know eight hours on one machine
and then you wanted to and you double
the number of machines that you want the
assumption is that it's gonna take four
hours right it doesn't work that way
because because of cluster management
and everything else it's probably gonna
take five hours so it's incredible that
it makes it can scale that close to I
think it's at 88291 percent depending on
the kind of network that you have now it
gives you that near linear scalability
across multiple devices and multiple
GPUs multiple machines so a paradigm
that we see is that some customers train
models in a cloud using the GPU
capability they don't want to keep it in
their environment because it's expensive
is you know and all the things and then
once they have the model artifact they
can take the same copy of a model and
push that to
an app that runs on them in a web app
and it can also take the same other
artifact and push that to the mobile and
then again the reason I'm giving this
background is that you can use art to
build the model and then upload the
model with another language and stuff
like that so this training and
deployment is usually a challenge in
production environment because the data
scientist loves R so she likes to just
type o code in R and then the production
code runs in C and then that's a six
month exercise to do like requirement
specifications or whatnot
after you don't figure out how to solve
a problem to get that to go to
production so it's another reason why we
like talking about that so we have a
number of people in the industry that
are contributing to M X net from Apple
MIT Microsoft is doing a lot of work in
that too and that's the 88 % capability
that I was talking about so let's get a
little technical into how you would
process all the workflow process and as
far as deep learning is concerned with
with with MX net but before that is
there any question in comment I'm
actually just trying to drink and I
should have planted some questions I can
have some friends in the room next time
ok so the typical process that you want
to do when you want to process data I
mean with deep learning and said you
need to I believe everyone here is
familiar with you know vectorizing your
data right whether you start from an
image data set or a text data set or I
don't know any sorts of you know data
set you need to come up with a vector or
a matrix or any form of deserialize
version of that data set that you're
going to pass to the model that you're
creating so we we typically start in
deep learning with tensors and then a
one-dimensional tensor is a vector
two-dimensional matrix I'm familiar with
that 3d tensor so this is what they look
like the API in MX net that helps you do
that it's a wrapper on top of numpy that
essentially gets you to build new umpire
arrays or new empire matrices or numpy
tensors of higher and higher and higher
ranks and so that's what you get with MX
net
and array and the next thing that you
need to do after you've ingested the
data in you know as a tensor is that you
want to build a neural network in order
to train your data right so there's a
couple of ways you can do that and MX
net supports both one is what we call
the decorative model and the other one
is imperative model and essentially the
idea here is that you you want to build
a computational graph you want to give
the the library the like like being in a
restaurant you say I want I want to
pizza with this topping on that topping
you don't need to worry how it's made of
done in the back end but you declare
that you want you know a certain
configuration of your of your network
and that's what the MX net the symbol
API does it gives you the possibility to
construct what we call a computational
graph by just describing the model that
you want to build and there's a few
neural network architectures from the
perceptron which is essentially a linear
combination of of inputs and into what
we call the feed-forward networks which
we're going to walk through today which
is a stacked up layered by layered you
know linear combinations and activations
and to a number for the ones and more
complex one like long short-term
memories and and and other things like
that for for different use cases so
typically for image analysis you have
people that build what we call cnn's
convolutional neural networks and I can
get to talk about it a little more later
if that's relevant but the idea is that
you start with an input layer what I was
talking about layer and then you have
what we call hidden layers these are the
neurons that are contributing to
learning stage by stage step by step the
construction of your input data set and
then so like I was saying you can from
the first layer learn what we call the
edges by just observing co-located
pixels and then trying to find out
what's the difference between them if
there's a rough change and you know some
of that there's an edge and then by a
combination of edges you can start week
you can start constructing intermediate
objects or
contours and finding out exactly
following an object all over all the
rounded picture and all the way up to
contributing all these learned stages
into making a final object and there's
this concept called upper layer which is
a decision layer or which is a
prediction layer or which is a
classification layer that's where you
sort of say okay this is what I saw into
this whole process so moving data from
the input layer to the upper layer is
called feed-forward and traditionally
what happens is that you pass data
forward and then you get a prediction
here what is not visible here is that
you also have a label like these lady
could be called I don't know Linda and
then so so you would have sent the
information out here that this is Linda
and based on the based on the prediction
that the neural network made there will
be an error and you would propagate the
error back and give each neuron the
responsibility over their contribution
over you know the error and then all
these connections are called weights so
all these connections are actually what
the deep neural network is doing right
so your your goal ultimately is to find
the proper parameters for all these
weights and you can see there's a lot of
them for just a one two three you know
hidden layers network so the more you
grow your deep neural network the more
weight to get typical neural networks
could have like up to 18 million or you
know weight and so that's really what is
consuming time you know in in processing
data with deep learning and so yeah is
that the question on that okay so the
next thing you want to do after you have
figured out how to ingest your input
dataset and how to and you've
constructed ideally you know the type of
neural networks that you want to
construct for the type of problems that
you want to solve is that you have an
optimization function or you have an
error function and it usually looks like
this right I'll put this all along thing
here to scare people but see like no one
is so yeah yeah I figured it out yeah
cool
usually I put it some people like okay
so so you usually have an arrow function
around optimization function of this
sort of regularization term and all that
that you now want to minimize right you
all you want to maximize depending on
what kind of you know function you have
and so the goal is to derive that
against each parameters that you picked
up into in in these weights so you
minimize that error function against all
these parameters and you're trying to
come up with output them with a minimum
possible and it has this linear
relationship because again the error is
contributed as it goes so you want to
make sure that you can as much as you
can process that in parallel and I'm
gonna talk about how it's done from the
hardware level so this is obviously a
bad configuration because as you know
with the number of GPUs and compute
capability that you want to have you
wanna you want to have a kernel
environment I can do all of these
operations in parallel so that you can
benefit from that and so the MX network
model sort of does that for you and the
next thing after you've trained your
models is that you know you you have a
certain number of parameters that impact
or influence the way you learn the goal
is to get to the minimum the minimum is
a star right here of the error and
there's a few ways to go about that I
believe you familiar with the gradient
descents or stochastic gradient descent
and then there's a momentum that gives
you a step of how fast you go into you
know finding a minimum and then there
are other optimization functions that
are becoming more and more popular like
atom at a grad or at a Delta which are
just variant on the gradient descent and
also take advantage of many batches
because the idea is that if you if you
if you do a the tsukasa gradients and
it's a lot more accurate but the
challenge there is that it's computing
the gradient on every single observation
and trying to optimize a greater than
every single observation but you can
take ten observations at a time and then
computer grading and you're gonna have
an error that is not too far from a
gradient that is not too far from what
you would have had if you
then if you had computed on every single
observation but you would have had saved
9x the time that you have spent if you
had gone on each observation training
and all that so there's a few ways to
make that you know happen faster and
that's where machine learning and deep
learning jumps into the art part of you
know the house right where the science
piece is figured out but how do you find
these optimized parameters the
initializers is the initial value that
you're going to give to your to your
connections your way to your neural
networks the optimizer is which one of
these are you going to choose and then
this learning rate scheduler is you know
how do you want to learning rate to
change over time you could say that
after this much iteration you know be
more aggressive or be less aggressive
and initially make big steps and then
once you start converting towards the
minimum stop making smaller steps
because you want to jump over the
minimum and then stop doing in other
stuff so there's a few things you can do
now to optimize here and that gives you
some opportunities and you also have a
few I put this here to sort of talk
about the vanishing gradient problem
where if your if your error becomes
smaller and smaller and smaller over
time the derivative is sort of going to
plateau to a zero sintered and then you
essentially not going to optimize
anymore so again these parameters in the
MX net libraries give you the
opportunity to essentially set the hyper
parameters and get your your network to
to minimize or to converge to the
minimum faster there's more that is
happening in a in the industry where you
can essentially upload this outsource
these responsibilities to a third party
system that is going to use Bayesian
optimization to find the proper hyper
parameter as fast for you I said
Bayesian optimization is happy that's
the kind of things so so you you get
your input data set you create the
tensors out of it you you create your
neural network structure based on the
problem you want to solve and then you
train that neural network on your
hardware GPU and whatnot and then you
optimize the parameters that you want to
apply to your neural network the next
thing you want to do is to scale it so
the typical process for training deep
Learning Network
is that from if you had just a single
machine you start with this initial data
set right so you have this data set and
then you split it because you want to
distribute that you have four GPUs in
your machine so you start by splitting
your data set from an input perspective
and so you read the data port partitions
and then that means you vectorize that
you create all the things that we talked
about earlier and after that so you have
a key value store that is external to
all these things then you need to pull
these parameters the Thetas or the
add-in coordinators but all these
connections all these weights that are
going through the neurons within your
deep neural network architecture so sort
of need to pull down the state from a
consistent view of the hope for the
whole machine after you pull down the
stage you know you you compute the
gradient right so you find the error and
then you minimize the error within the
different GPUs within the machine and
then every GPU is probably hosting of
your copy of the model of a section of
the model so they all compute things
locally and then they send a gradient
back to the to the key value store which
is external to the cluster right and
then after that you update the weight
within the cluster based on error so
that's the whole process that you have
connections you make an error you pull
these connections if you computer
gradient you minimize it and then your
update to wait and then you go on and on
on again multiple iterations until you
converge to a point where you satisfied
with your error and then you've trained
a deep neural network so if you want to
move from these configuration of you
know single machine to having multiple
machines that are working separately
because MXN uses an external key value
store you essentially have no change in
your code so instead of and it's a big
problem like if you familiar with
multiple parallel you know processing
type of compute or MPI I was talking to
some people that were doing
power processing back in the 90s and in
the work me to retain that they had I'm
so happy that I wasn't there then
because they had to write all the
parallelism code and had to make
machines talk to each other manually I
see his nothing service probably he
probably knows something about it so
yeah all of these things and so one of
the key challenges for these new deep
learning libraries is to make it
possible for P
to move from one single machine single
GP or multiple GPU processing to
multiple machines in a cluster or
multiple GPU and all that and then you
just don't change the code right you
just send it and then the framework
takes care of it
so that's that and then the the last
thing from a technical perspective that
you need to look at is you know how do
you input the data so there's a there is
an i/o library that essentially makes it
possible for you to ingest data there's
no picture here so you can start with
the MX net the i/o and and then create
your own iterator for your data
ingestion or you can use a record IO to
ingest record data or voice data or you
can use a metal image to ingest images
so we've sort of walked through the
iterator for you and you just have to
use it so I'm going to quickly go
through because we have to have to show
you a demo but I'm gonna quickly go
through how you can get started on AWS
environment with everything that I just
talked about and just some five or six
slides about that so the first thing is
that you need to ingest data I believe
you're familiar with that so you either
upload data or use Kinesis for real-time
data set for production but you should
never underestimate the bandwidth of a
FedEx truck so we have these AWS
snowball edge that essentially gives you
100 terabytes a data transport
capability with onboard computer has a
couple of Kindles on it a Kindle at the
top for the label and the Kindle on the
side for manipulating add cables and
everything you plug it to your
environment and then you push it to the
crowd customers love snowball age so
this is a fun take where they always
take selfies with a snowball you know
when when they have it and then they
ship it back to us so if you use
snowball send us your pictures and my
next presentation will have a picture in
it and then if you have a bigger
requirement well we have with snow
mobile which essentially gives you torn
and petabyte capability and then we our
customers fight for sitting next to the
driver like I want to drive it I want to
drive it so it takes about six weeks to
load and then six weeks to unload we
give it to security 24/7 and all the
and these are the racks in there right
so it's like a whole deer center move so
and after you've ingested the data well
you have multiple data stores in there
sources for multiple workloads s3
Glacier Aurora for relational database
services and all that and after that you
have a whole family of compute
capabilities right from ec2 to lambda
which is our event based processing
compute and then for EMR which is
elastic MapReduce where you can have
essentially Big Data the Hadoop
ecosystem automated and ability to
launch a spark cluster of a thousand
machines if you want auto scaling up and
down with security and a lot of other
features a lot of it because I used to
work there and then like right away or
redshift which is a bi database and an
Athena which allows you to query data AG
straight from the data source without
having to have a cluster running server
less data processing and quick side
which is you know for data visualization
and Amazon ai which is I haven't spoken
about everything but it's the family of
product that gives you the capability to
do a ad processing and to wrap it all
around you know we have Amazon glue
which is essentially an ETL solution
that helps you create pipelines of you
know end and processing of your data set
right and Mechanical Turk is has a
tagline of artificial artificial
intelligence where you have a job that
you know requires human intelligence
like recognizing specific objects within
an image and you can create a job send
that to people and then degree they
create the ground truth data set that
you use for for your machine learning
job and then security is a top priority
it's most important things so we wrap
everything else you read in the aid of
your security environments so jumping on
our which is the other you know
important factor of look of the talk
today so who here is not familiar with
our no one so I can just stop here right
great
so our came from you know the Bell Labs
and it was created by John Chambers
1976 I'm trying not to mess up here
because he gives me lessons about our
time so I'm watching my I'm sitting I'm
standing next to our maybe for everyone
so I'm watching my mouth here and so
John Chen was created as the language s
which became pretty popular in the
seventies and then back in 1993 a couple
of guys Robert gentleman and Rossi Hakka
create in the University of Auckland
created our language and so our is
pretty cool I use it a lot when I want
to benchmark certain our boredom or when
I want to essentially solve a problem
because I think it's one of the most
mature machine learning libraries out
there it gives you the possibility to
solve a lot of problems almost
automatically
I remember when for example if you were
using cycle learn and number for the
tools to do cross-validation or grid
search or a number of things you know
it's one line command in R and in you
have to code like 15 lines and other
languages so it's really a quick step
into solving a problem at this benchmark
and what you want to solve and so it
gives you the possibility to do
interesting things like plotting
probability functions and just
statistics in general and with some nice
graphics the other thing is that you can
you know do some traditional machine
learning I fit functions you know with R
and this is a sampling simple example of
you know linear regression where you can
predict the Suns height based on having
the fighters height as you can see it's
very it's not really finding any pattern
but anyway and then you can also have
you know a hierarchical clustering with
like building dendrograms and the back
you know bone behind random forests and
all that where you can use our one
command and you dig deeper into data set
and next thing that you can do is then
you can have nice plottings and nice
graphics no built from our and this is
very very important for the data science
process because it's very iterative it's
a good quote about you know data science
that what a to quotes that are like one
is that they're scientists spend 80
percent of their time who can finish
that
and 20% of their time complaining about
cleaning the data yeah so so it's a very
iterative and painful process the other
fun quote is that you need to torture
the data long enough for it to start
telling you the truth so once you have
data it's it's we really need to look at
it's there you know and and then sort of
process that for a long time that's the
opportunity we are gives you a very very
easy way to do that and now the the
claim that you know we are making
instead you can also use are for
building deep neural networks right so
you can do it
MX net is available you can just upload
the libraries like library MX net like
everything else I have sample code
tricks to install it it's lightweight
you can run it on your computer or you
can run it in the cloud or you can run
it I don't know multiple environments
and then essentially build your your
deep neural network and then benchmark
that so with that how much time do we
have charge time right 15 okay so with
that we're going to move to the code
walkthrough where I'm going to show you
how to essentially solve a problem or
with with MX net here so the first thing
I'm going to show you is how to who here
has an AWS account how is everyone I
appreciate the business who here doesn't
have an AWS account I'm just playing so
so when you get on the AWS
infrastructure you know we we high-level
you know we sort of trying to solve the
IT and automation and like a few
problems that people are facing when
when they're building intelligent system
or when they're building systems in
general so it's a long story but
essentially some cool quotes is that
every developer has an average of about
three new features a day you know when
they use it of us right so there's a lot
of features we'll have about 90 plus
products and services now from anything
from compute to storage to Internet of
Things through contact centers now game
developing mobile hub and application
that pretty much everything and analysis
and artificial intelligence nowadays
right so this is where I spend most of
my time but in my first couple of years
at AWS I was working here mostly like my
team was supporting these products and
then for data migration virtual private
you know clouds where you can have a
whole virtual data center on on top of
the it obvious environment and bi so
it's a lot going on on AWS environment
so where what's interesting for us is
easy - easy - is where you can have
virtual machines you know as a service
where you can essentially launch a
machine and then it's pre-configured or
you can configure it all yourself so
when you go to lunch and an instance you
have a few choices there from Ubuntu
Amazon Linux and then a few other
choices here you could also have your
own custom machine image as you can see
I have a deep learning army including
our package because I installed it we
compiled the environment with our myself
and I can share that code with you I
used to give a class on on IOT and then
that's a bootcamp client machine for the
IOT and I have this machine now that I
called eigen machine learning which is
my my default data science box but we
also have this AWS marketplace where you
have prepackaged and pre-configured
machines that have essentially a bunch
of you know software already
pre-installed I think we have about 36
categories now and and more than 36 or
38 thousand products I don't keep track
anymore but it's a lot of them in
multiple families from e-commerce
education financial services and what
now and so all of that so the idea here
is that the machine will be
pre-configured prepackaged and you can
just launch it and use the software that
sits on top of it many people that put
machines on the market pays charge for
it sorry but the deep learning army
which is the mesh
gene that we would build and maintain we
don't charge a an extra for it
so if you go up there and search for AWS
deep learning army you have a few
choices right you have the deep learning
army with Amazon Linux version which is
the CentOS you know the right version
and you have the deep learning army
Ubuntu version if you're a new boot and
a boon to person and so you can just
select the machine here and you have the
configuration so you will pay for the
machine you send you you launched the
deep learning army on and as you can see
the software is zero so we don't charge
for it but we charge you for ec2 and you
say continue and you've selected the
machine image that you want and then you
need to select the hardware you want to
run the machine on we have a few machine
types here and the GPU family you can
say we also have FPGA which i think is a
bit crazy for people that are interested
in it but if you say GPU instances and
then so these are the g2 family of
instances GPU which we started launching
in in 2013 and then people are using
that for image processing or game
processing and all these things but if
you spec GPU compute you have the p2
instance families that have a lot more
GPU capability for example if I select
the fee to eight extra-large I believe
he has eight GPU chips in it and 16
extra large has 16 GPUs in it so that's
the one that gives you about 40,000 cuda
cores and i go to the configuration of
the storage and you know select all the
parameters as storage to the machine i
say i want 500 gigs of disk attached to
the machine i say i want to tag it if i
want to or not i want to configure a
security group the security groups I
essentially wrappers around the machine
right it's like a firewall that sits
with the machine do I want to open this
port or not like in this case the port
22 is open and I can decide to open it -
just my IP this current IP or not but
anyway these are easy to features
and and then I launch it right and I
select a key pair that I want to use to
SSH into the box acknowledge that I
selected that key pair and I'll launch
the machine so it's as easy as that so
that's the first part of a demo like
with this machine launch failed for
whatever reason this this is where you
promised that the demo was working
before like us where it was working
before so yeah so I only have a limit of
one I can go in and so because I already
have a picture running and that's the
cool thing actually this is I'm gonna
act like Atlantis so so I did of yes we
have the concept of you know launch it
because it's very easy to launch like
hundreds and thousands of machines so we
applied default default limits to the
number of machines you can launch so
that people fall in this and then they
actually call us or they go through
their admin in their companies and say I
need more and then it's a it's a very
specific process it's like I want more
machine and then we can increase your
limit and then you can much more so yeah
I can only have a few peaches and I
already have one running I'm gonna
cancel this launch and so after you
launched it it looks like this and then
this is this is a p2 that I have running
right now like where it essentially you
have access to a public dns for your
machine where you can just go on an
interface and so I have a bootstrap
scrape on this machine I can actually
show it to you or is user data about
what for instance is in two days
in settings view changes oh it's not
here anyway I'll show you I'll show the
scrapers so when I saw so I have this
scrape that essentially I don't know if
you can see it I don't know how to
zoomed it but I can share it so
essentially what I do here is that after
I launch my machine and that's the way
you can push that to - to the machine
when once it's up you can run a certain
number you can essentially run the bash
script on top of it so what I do here is
that after I create the machine I
install some libraries that are like
using a bunch of things like T marks H
top and whatnot and then I I saw our
studio and in our studio a server in
order to access our by a browser I have
a few I our script that I like apply
predictive modeling the examples so if
you have that book this is pretty cool
you probably recognize most of these
packages and then I do install what is
that shiny server to server and you see
the password of my instance there and
then I add a lot of things so I
installed a mex net essentially by by
recompiling the by recompiling the our
package for MX net because the current
version of our deep learning
Tommy doesn't hasn't compiled it with
our package but it's very easy it's
sensually this much you know scripting
and then I have our support within the
GPU enable machine running on the cloud
and and what I can do is that I can just
go and our studio afterwards and then I
have this whole you know interface right
with shiny you know and all these things
so that's the idea the idea is that if
you want to benefit from the potential
of the cloud you know you you start the
machine like that you run this booster
scrape and then now you have access to
are running in the cloud with GPU
support and enough capacity as you want
so that's the that's the whole workflow
so another thing the way the machine
looks
in the backend is like this right so
after you get a machine what I do here
is that I can SSH into the box and when
I get into the box
can everybody see correctly right so
when I get into the box I have added
some stuff there but I have this source
package that has everything
pre-installed I pre-configured so we we
added everything from deep learning the
most popular deep learning library is
cafe anaconda 2 & 3 so we can also do
the traditional you know psychic learned
everything else you would want to do
there have tensorflow which is very
popular and then we did something else
in compiling linear algebra you know
acceleration libraries like often
blasted in algebra subsystems and other
ones we have the Intel Mac math kernal
acceleration also library they're
pre-configured and installed we try to
go through the pain of doing that
manually and then it's it's a headache
so you have it there just use it and
then you can either go to MX net here
and then get into some example you know
so you have the whole source code here
and and you have a bunch of examples
there right for I mean it's not enough
time to show you everything but you have
some fancy stuff like auto encoder or
adversary examples so who here is
familiar with gun like generative
adversarial networks a where are you
trying to trick a you know a network by
getting a discriminator and then and
then I forgot how the other one is
called but anyway so we have examples
their style transfer I talked about a
bunch of ipython notebooks and there
also are examples there so you can just
go ahead and use that so going back to
the front-end so what I've done is that
I installed the machine installers to
your server shiny and everything and it
gives me this interface where I can
write my code right now getting into the
code for the last 10 minutes that we
have the code is actually available
online on Jared's website we gave a
webinar about a couple of months ago
where we walk people through this so we
made a decision to go through a code
walkthrough instead of going to a live
demo because you never know what can
happen so essentially the process here
is that what we upload some samar
packages for doing a few things like
pre-processing data and doing some
useful stuff and we had extra boost
there too because we wanted to compare
some accuracies but it's a very very
simple small data set simple network
model that we created we have data we
created a feed-forward network remember
what I talked about we passed data
through we have a number of helper
functions so it's all there on the right
side so in just all these packages so
you're familiar with days I'll skip that
the dataset that we had is the New York
City planning data set that essentially
gives you the valuation of certain
houses and accommodation in different
districts of of New York so the
traditional process here is that we read
the CSV they are set and then we
validate some of that data set and also
we read the training and test and
validation data set so it's the same the
same approach that you have with a
traditional machine learning where you
have your training and then tested asset
but the deep learning ecosystem adds the
validation step where you you train it
you validate it and then you test it
it's just an extra step in validation so
what we do here is that we take out the
features that we want to use for
training and again this is just a demo
but you can go with it at scale and you
leave everything in there if you want
the idea is that you don't have to
babysit the dataset because the act of
minimizing the error function is going
to select it's gonna do regularization
for you and there's certain number of
things that you have to explicitly give
to the network to the model so we select
a few variables like the total value the
borough the School District Council a
few things about the data set and we do
the same for validation and test data
set so after that we look at a data set
a little bit so we see that it's pretty
normal in our stuff and
then we take a list of the data and then
here we just want to plot the data to
have like a distribution if we have
issues of like class imbalance or or
whatnot and I believe at a point here we
what are we doing here Jared like hi
yeah cash balances so that's exactly
what we're doing so we're trying to find
out what is the class by balance on the
data set and so the response that we all
have of the target whatever we want to
predict is you know whether it's high or
not but the value is higher not based on
the threshold that we set and so we get
to write the variable names and this all
of this is normal this is their
pre-processing that you would have done
we're just preparing our entire dataset
for processing no deep neural networks
happening yet the next thing that we're
doing is that we use the V trick package
that essentially does feature
engineering for you you can do design
treatment see - essentially it runs a
certain number of data pre-processing
libraries or code on top of your data
set in order to come up with a final
version of like removing variants non
variant data set or treating outliers or
treating a certain number of things
about your data set so it does that for
you by default and that's why I like R
because it just does it for you and then
you can prepare your data set for after
treatment you create matrices off of
your data set for for your training set
and an outcome same thing for the
validation set and the outcome and then
the test set and the outcome and and
essentially putting that in sports
models so that you don't you don't use
all the space on under this with zero
values so again this is pre-processing
so what we are now is where the deep
learning or the MX net part begins the
library is extensible enough for you to
come up with a custom error metric and
in this case it didn't support the lock
loss the multivariate lock loss and then
we created a custom metric that we added
we attached to the MX the metric that
custom in order to essentially have a
multivariate law class function which
essentially does a lot loss on top of
the the
you know the error function that you
want to have and this is where we
construct the neural network so it is as
simple as having the symbol API that I
talked about where you're constructing
the dynamic graph or the computational
graph of your of your model you create
you start by creating a variable the
variable is a placeholder that
represents the data set that you want to
pass in to the model so after creating
the variable the next thing that we do
is we do a drop out drop out is
essentially the idea of drop out is that
because your networks learned by you
passing data through the model the idea
is that if you drop a certain percentage
of the models as you pass the first
iteration of the data and you randomly
drop another percentage of the neurons
in the model the network's is going to
be forced to learn because it doesn't
have the same neurons involved in the
processing at all time so that's why we
randomly drop in this case 20% of the of
the of the neurons that would
participate in the learning process and
after that we do a fully connected the
fully connected layers are what we saw
before where you have every neurons in a
certain layer participating receiving
inputs from every neurons from the layer
before that being the input layer or an
intermediate layer so we and when you
say a number of hidden here is 256
essentially saying that we won the first
we want to generate we want to have a
fully connected layer which has 256
output neurons which has 256 neurons and
I would do batch normalization which is
no normal aging as you know it right for
for every batch we normalize you know
the data set in order to not have crazy
behaviors and after that we'll do
activation so again activation is the
whole concept of after linear
combination you activated that's where
you replicate the behavior of the brain
and in this case we use the relu there's
a few functions that exist in activation
world you can use sigmoid which is what
a lot of people are familiar with and
relu essentially makes activation or
derivation faster because the function
is f of X is equal to X if X is greater
than zero or is equal to zero if X is
less than zero so to derive f of X is X
is just 1 and if it's less than 0 is 0
so
even faster and it was not proven to be
less accurate than the other complex
functions and that's why we use rather
then we do drop out again we should
familiar with and then the pipes here
are essentially a ways to chain that
again we're building a graph so we just
passing instruction from layer to layer
and we do another fully connected layer
of 128 so we started with 256 down to
128 another normalization another
activation another drop out now at this
point we are ready to make a prediction
on the outcome that we want to get right
the outcome is whether the price the the
value of their property is high or not
so it's a logistic regression and then
for that we have a fully connected layer
with one single you know hidden neuron
which is going to have one neuron that
we attach to a one logistic regression
output layer right so that's that's the
essential constructor for deep neural
networks are you you start with an input
data as input data set
you build fully connected layers and
then the idea is that you go from high
to low 256 128 down to one output layer
where you force every linear combination
to go down into one and then after that
you activate you apply logistic
regression output there which means that
you put a logic on top of that and you
get the probability of if it's on the
zero you know if it's bit low point five
you know it's low if you're silent point
five is a time so we've created the the
we've constructed the deep neuron work
we haven't done anything with it yet and
so that's what we do here here we we
just type net and then we see that it's
a C++ object again we wrote yeah quick
question
no you don't yeah we don't need to that
it's it's it's endowed by default just
takes care of it yeah we don't do that
explicitly here I know what you mean so
the bias is the extra you can encode
that if you want but when you construct
the layers this way you we don't need to
do that so the framework is gonna take
care of that because in the end the bias
is going to be optimized as well if you
want to force if you want to create a
specific if you want to add a specific
neuron that would contribute in the bias
you can encode that yourself using the
imperative you know aspect of FMX net
but we don't do that in this case okay
so after you've created it the the
neural net object has a certain number
of arguments where it has the data
variable that we talked about earlier it
has a definitions of the different like
you see here you see the weight to back
to your question my friend you see the
weight and bias there so we didn't have
to specify it but it was created by
default that's what I meant
so we add that you could add it if you
want but we add it and then we have this
library called graphviz that can help
you visualize your network right so it
gives you a good insight into what
you've been doing oops sorry well you
know you can have a good plot that's say
okay I'd get the data in a drop it out I
get fully connected layers normalize it
activate it and off you go and off you
go
and this is really the simplest
construct of of deep neural network and
you see it everywhere in many
implementations most complex network
take a small structure like that and
then start stacking them up like Lego
blocks to build more complicated stuff
so after that we want to train the
network so in this case we we did that
on Jared's laptop so we added you know
CPU threads we force it to work with
CPUs and then MXN has a seed
you know function to essentially force a
person we produce civility in your code
to come up because we randomized at a
point we want to make sure that every
time you run the code you generally the
same random values so that if I share my
code you can come up to the same result
and so at this point we accept to see
two days we set the environment to use
for threads of a CPU and then we use M X
net model but feed-forward library to
essentially pass you know bind the the
network structure that we created to the
data set that we have created in
matrices and iterators and that's what
we do here so the symbols construct is a
computational graph of the network that
we created and then the X is the
training data the wise the the outcome
of the training data set the optimizer
remember when I was talking about
optimizer the the evaluation data and in
the context this is the interesting part
the context is where you want to run the
code so if you want to move from CPU to
GPU it is as easy as MX the GPU or MX to
CPU if what I run on 10 GPUs if you have
10 GPUs it is as easy as a list of MX
that all GPUs that you have if you have
multiple machines you have to specify a
key value store which is external to
this machine so you choose one machine
to host the key value store and then you
point out every other machines there and
it's going to do all the processing that
we talked about and then you show the
evaluation metric which is the M
multi-class law clause that we spoke
about earlier
you tell it how many times you wanted to
you know pass the data through the
network and this is important because we
use drop out and remember drop out
randomly chooses to a certain percentage
of a data set it wants to drop of the
neurons who wants to drop and use it
that way with a batch size for the multi
batch you know grading competition and
that's just a structure of how the data
is within the room age of individual and
that's that after you run that it runs
for white range in familiar with the
training process and after that we
construct the prediction function and
and then we use the the normal predict
from a function to essentially pass new
observation to the model that we created
yeah with a certain layout and then
after that we we come we would look at
accuracy so what we started doing after
that is train the same neural network
with a few other traditional ways that
we familiar with like with a elastic net
model from GLM net it's as easy as that
it takes it takes less steps but you
know the claim that we what what achieve
is that you know deep learning is better
but for this data set things are
actually very very very common you get
you get to the error margin it's not
that large but we wanted to compare so
here we're exploring so the whole demo
is over here because you can train
models in your product but then we did a
little bit of elastic net and then we
also have predation savings into an
object yeah we specify initial
initializer if we don't specify an
initializer it's going to take the
default which is a Gaussian you know the
normal distribution so it's just going
to throw Gaussian distributions at it
okay that's a good question yeah so and
it's a few other initializer there's
another one called xaviar and then other
ones yeah so we we did that here and
then we do we create we also train an
extra boost model on top of that extra
boost was hard to beat right because
it's fast it's accurate I think it was
you know best performing model on this
data set but I'm proud that the MX net
team is also the team that created the
extra boost so that was my argument when
it came out dad was like extra boost is
better I was like it's the same team so
and then so we also had predictions and
we also did something with perfecting
machines in order to compare so the
whole thing is about comparing and then
we plot our sees for all these models
and then this is a performance here
right where extra boost is like really
really hard to beat you know it
converges really fast the area under the
curve is much larger but I can see the
margin is not that large and it's very
small data set but yeah so the net is
there and then so the neural network is
actually well over time it was you know
sort of better but
it's out I could do so these are within
a very very small standard deviation I
think what did we say when we were
presenting on the rule like as you can
see these are all doing very well and
they are performing almost equally so
the the goal is really to compare we
wanted to have something visual but the
goal was to show the process of
constructing a neural network as easy as
that visualizing that in our interface
that you spun up from these
infrastructure so with that that's the
end of a demo I'll take questions and
all comments also go back to the
presentation and then share my contact
in case you want to reach out happy to
talk to you that's my email shoot me an
email if you have
yeah how do I pick them so the question
is when you train the models how do you
pick the parameters which parameters are
you talking about yeah so that's that's
sort of where the art the art part of
the neural networks is coming in if it's
about the network structure what people
do is that for the problem they're
trying to solve they usually start with
something that already works and it's
there are some very popular networks out
there like the VG gene and like the rest
net and all that so if you have an image
recognition problem you can start with
that and this is concept called transfer
learning and then no one can really
clearly explain to you why they chose
this much layer and did that much stuff
but the idea is that they work and it
was done almost experimentally and then
it with a lot of trial and errors but it
works as of now so you can start with
that and then transfer learning is about
cutting off the top layer the upper
layer of these models and then adding
your own models for example if it's a
model that was trained on recognizing a
million people you can only train that
on recognizing you and your friend
right so there's there's some there's
some guidelines like if you have an
image processing you know that's where
you go down to understanding the
structure of different networks if you
have an image processing problem you
probably want to work with convolutional
neural networks because the structure is
about you know like running a filter on
top of an image and then coming up with
image structures if you have a data set
there has a temporal dependency that's
where recurrent neural networks are very
popular right or recursive neural
networks if you have some special
relationship between objects within your
networks so there are a number of papers
out there a number of canonical networks
that sort of give you intuition and
guideline unfortunately you sort of have
to read them all and then not all but at
least a few of them and get familiar
with what would sort of fit your problem
space but typically your problem space
would lie in text data set or text
processing or image processing or video
or audio processing so these top-level
problems would guide you towards a
certain set of neural network constructs
or cell types and then you can start
getting into more complex cell types
like LST aims or gr use or there's a lot
more fancy ones that people are creating
every day but the way out go about it is
that I'll start with a simple one that
fits the problem space that I'm trying
to resolve probably reuse a model that
exists already or take that network
structure and instead of trying to prove
enough
so I tried running that code
yeah
right we could do that waves right thank
you
[Applause]